Vsauce good to see you all here a few
weeks ago I saw it in your sleep
submitted a great fallout 3 glitch and
by great I mean booty shakin I was so
inspired I decided to cover some more
Vsauce video game WTF and first off
Fallout New Vegas where right off the
bat this guy likes to get creepy in
Madden NFL 11 you can get hit in the
nuts where's the ball you ask a hoe
this guy has magic ball returning nuts
the only thing more fun is playing
basketball topless but be careful where
you blow things up or you might get this
and be careful when you cheat and portal
this guy tried third person and wound up
with a gun in the butt the dough don't
worry he changed it to a crowbar and now
mash ups here's one you'll love pokemons
in Fallout New Vegas apparently they'll
just follow you around and fight on your
side now what's this guy riding through
San Andreas scooter segway no no Sonic
the Hedgehog but my favorite combination
is super mario world leading portal now
Mario doesn't get a portal gun but he
can use what's there and just like the
original it's all very puzzle based
brown water kills you and the cute
little turret guys are bullet Bill's by
the way a reddit user pretty much won
the Internet last week with these
mirrors mod with back lights to look
like real life portals now consider some
console and PC mods a few are just
cosmetic like alligator skin with an
eyeball others are microwave pcs
complete within inside a microwave
desktop wallpaper but if your scan to
the radiation just warm up with a
toaster instead a working supermen
toaster we've all seen the massive NES
tabletop controller but thinking smaller
here's an NES game playing inside the
cartridge itself but let's say you owned
a Dreamcast a Nintendo 64 and Xbox an
Atari 2600 a Sega Saturn and NES and
SNES and a PlayStation how do you
organize them all easy inside the
ultimate gaming machine r2d2 you can
turn any website into a katamari Fun
Zone by copy and pasting the JavaScript
code in this video's description into
your browser's URL bar it works best in
Chrome but when you
press Enter you will be able to use your
mouse to move around a ball that picks
up items on the page and grows larger
the bigger it gets the larger the
objects it can pick up before we leave
what modifications would you want for
your own system of ps3 that cooks you
bacon an Xbox that you can make out with
and take to the prom leave your ideas in
the comments below and once you have go
check out my new episode of boat on
vsauce2 where I show you the world's
biggest holes click right here for that
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]